[Music]
praise be to god who has given us islam
who has led us to a faith so exalted and
who in his mercy has granted us our
prophet to intercede for us let us pass
to our subject and write of that prince
strong to aid who re-established the
doctrine of the true faith and struck to
earth the worshipers of the cross
he who was the prosperity of the world
and of the faith of islam and of the
muslims the warrior who delivered the
holy city from the hands of the
polytheists
with my own eyes i have seen men who
fought in god's cause display a hardy
hood in the midst of danger which would
surpass belief
i myself have seen wonderful deeds which
heart and brain could hardly conceive
actions so marvelous that the tongue
would be powerless to picture them and
the hand to describe them on paper
nevertheless these deeds are of such a
nature that he who knows them cannot
keep them concealed and he who has
witnessed them feels compelled to pass
on to others a narrative of the wonders
he has seen
having taken ascalon and the districts
around jerusalem the sultan devoted all
his energies to preparations for an
expedition against the city he was
anxious to make the most of his
opportunities now that the door of
success had been opened to him following
the advice of the holy prophet who said
he to whom the door of success has been
opened must take the opportunity and
enter in for he knows not when the door
may be shut upon him
the enemies of god saw they were menaced
by a disaster which they could not
escape
and by diverse signs it was revealed to
them that the city would fall into the
hands of the muslims
expecting to suffer the same fate as
their brothers and to die by the same
sword that had cut them down they
adopted the only alternative and asked
for a treaty that their lives might be
spared a treaty was concluded and the
sultan was put in possession of
jerusalem on friday the 27th of reject
the huge cross that rose from the dome
of the sakura was thrown down in this
manner by means of the sultan god
recorded a magnificent triumph to islam
when the sultan heard that the franks
were marching upon akka he felt the
greatest anxiety
the numbers of the franks kept on
increasing until at last they were
sufficiently strong to blockade the city
and prevent anyone from going in or
coming out it was resolved at the
council to attack the franks with all
our strength and to overwhelm them in
order to effect a passage
the attack was commenced after the hour
of friday's prayer in order that we
might benefit by the supplications of
the preachers from their pulpits
several terrible charges were made and
the battle raged until night closed in
and separated the combatants
[Applause]
the soldiers of both sides grew so
accustomed to meeting that sometimes a
muslim and a frank would leave off
fighting in order to have a conversation
sometimes the two parties would mingle
together singing and dancing so intimate
they had become and afterwards they
would begin fighting again
one day warying of this constant warfare
the soldiers of both sides said to one
another how long are the men to fight
without allowing the boys to share in
the pleasure let us arrange a fight
between the two parties of young fellows
this one from your side the other from
ours
boys were fetched from the city to
contend with the frankish youths the two
bands fought furiously and one of the
young muslims seized a young infidel
raised him in the air and threw him to
the ground making him prisoner
a frank ransomed to the prisoner for two
gold pieces
this is a strange occurrence such as
very seldom happens
[Music]
this video was sponsored by magellan tv
the documentary streaming service
question what was the largest islamic
empire was it a the umayyad caliphate b
the ottoman empire or c the mughal
empire that's right it was the umayyads
covering more than 11 million kilometers
and followed up by the equally ginormous
abbasids impressive and so a great
recommendation from magellan's
collection this week is the quran a
journey to the book's origin a
fascinating dive into the world into
which islam was born magellan tv have
supported this channel for more than a
year and they're a great choice if you
like documentaries and want more context
to our videos they have more than 3 000
works to choose from
click on the link in the description for
an exclusive month-long free trial for
voices of the past viewers thanks
[Music]
the king of england was very powerful
very brave and full of resolution
he had distinguished himself in many a
battle and displayed the greatest
boldness in all his campaigns
as regards his kingdom and rank he was
inferior to the king of france but he
outstripped him in wealth in valor and
in fame as a soldier it was reported of
him that on his arrival in cyprus he
made up his mind not to proceed any
further until he had taken the island
and reduced it to submission
[Music]
the enemy heard that several bodies had
been detached from our army and that the
right wing had been much weakened by the
departure of the troops belonging to the
various districts through which the
germans proposed to march
the franks therefore resolved to come
out and fall upon that wing whilst they
were not expecting the attack
but they became the sport of the vain
hopes that they had entertained when our
people saw them coming out in order of
battle they called to arms and rushed
out of their tents as a lion springs
from his lair the sultan sprang to his
horse crying on
for islam
the sultan had just left his tent when i
saw him he'd only a few officers with
him some of his men had not yet mounted
their horses when he came galloping up
as anxious as a mother who has lost her
only son he ordered his drum to be
beaten and his emirs replied by ordering
theirs to be sounded from the different
positions where they were posted
everyone was now on the saddle but by
this time the franks had hurled
themselves on the right wing they seized
everything that they found in the
tencent marketplace killing and
pillaging right and left they reached
the store tent and carried off part of
the liquors that were kept there when we
saw them thus fully occupied we
commanded our men to charge
the whole of the right wing was already
engaged when extra troops would been
summoned afterwards hurled themselves on
the franks like lions springing on their
prey
god delivered the enemy into their hands
they were completely routed and fled
headlong back to their camp whilst the
sword of god did execution upon them
separating their souls from their bodies
and severing their heads from their
shoulders
the fight was maintained without
interruption and scarcely an hour had
passed before we saw our enemies
prostrate as though they were palm trees
thrown down
the whole ground between our camp and
that of the enemy a distance of a
parasang or perhaps a little more was
covered with bodies
mounted on my mule i passed through a
sea of blood and tried to count the
number of dead but there were so many
that i could not reckon them
i noticed the bodies of two women
someone told me that he had seen four
women engaged in the fight two of whom
were taken prisoners the number of men
made captive that day was very
inconsiderable for the sultan had
commanded his troops to spare none who
should fall into their hands
it was indeed a bitter day for the
infidels different authorities are not
agreed as to the number of their dead
some say eight thousand others seven i
met an intelligent man one of our
soldiers who was going up and down the
lines counting the dead and i asked him
how many he'd counted
he replied so far there are
4060 odd
winter had now come on and the sea was
tossed by storms it was therefore
certain that the enemy would not engaged
in a pitched battle we knew also that
the heavy rains would prevent them
making any progress in the siege of the
city
therefore the sultan permitted his
troops to return to their respective
countries to rest and give their horses
time to recover before the season
arrived to recommence
fighting
the sea now became navigable once more
and the time drew near for the arrival
of reinforcements to both armies to
enable them to carry on the war
meanwhile the franks remained under the
walls of akka awaiting the results of
the war between the two parties
letters came in from akka beseeching us
in the most urgent matter to send them
help and begging us to so occupy the
enemy that they should be forced to
discontinue the assault the sultan
therefore informed his troops that he
had decided to advance closer to the
enemy and to invest their camp more
completely the garrison was so worn out
with exertion and fatigue that they sent
incessant complaints to the sultan
nevertheless they bore up with
considerable patience and god is with
the patient
meanwhile the sultan never ceased
attacking the enemy he fought them
continually night and day either in
person or by means of his officers and
sons with the view of distracting their
attention and preventing them from
prosecuting the siege
the two sides were still engaged in
fighting when the king of england
arrived
the news of his coming spread great
terror the franks were filled with so
great a joy at his arrival that they lit
huge and terrible fires that night in
their camp a sure sign of the important
support he had brought them their
leaders had often times boasted to us
that he would come and held his arrival
as a menace over our heads and now
according to the people who frequented
their camp they expected the very moment
he landed
to see him fill their dearest wish of
pushing forward with the siege of the
city
we constantly receive news from the
people in the city they besought us to
occupy the enemy's attention and
complained of being obliged to fight
both night and day the enemies continued
their assaults on the city and played on
the walls incessantly with their
manganelles until all the stonework and
structure of the walls was ruined
the people of the city were worn out by
fatigue taking no rest night or day
whilst the besiegers who hemmed them in
were in great force
[Music]
one of the muslims who had left the
trenches reported that he had seen a man
a frank of enormous stature who all
alone on the top of the parapet was
holding the muslims at bay by his own
unaided strength his comrades stood on
either side and handed him stones which
he hurled at our men as they advanced to
the scarp this man said he had been
struck by more than 50 arrows and stones
but nothing distracted him from his work
he kept on fighting and driving back the
men who were coming on until at last he
was burnt alive by a bottle of naphtha
held at him by one of our pyrotechnists
eventually a man swam out from the city
with letters
these informed us that the garrison were
reduced to the last extremity and were
too weak to defend the breach which was
now very large
they saw death himself looming before
them and feared that everyone would be
put to the sword if the city were
carried by storm
they had therefore concluded a treaty of
peace by which the city with all that it
contained its engines of war stores and
ships
was to be surrendered to the franks the
besieged had also promised to give up
the cross of the crucifixion
when the sultan had learned the contents
of the letter from the city he expressed
the greatest displeasure
full of anxiety he determined to send
the man back to the city that night with
a letter declaring his formal
disapproval of a treaty containing such
conditions
he was still in a state of anxiety when
all of a sudden the muslims saw the
banners of the infidels floating from
the walls of the city with crosses and
the distinctive penance of their leaders
whilst fires were lighted on the
ramparts
at that time i happened to be on duty in
the sultan's tent and seeing him struck
down with grief like a mother who had
lost her child
i offered him all the consolations that
are usual in such a case
begging him to think of the future fate
of the other cities of the coast and of
jerusalem
itself and to turn his attention to
delivering the muslim captives in akka
[Music]
messengers went constantly to and fro
between the two armies engaged in trying
to lay the foundations of a permanent
treaty of peace
commissioners employed by the franks to
examine the installment we had in
readiness for them reported that we had
fulfilled the conditions imposed except
with regard to the prisoners whom they
had specially named and who had not all
been brought together
they therefore let the negotiations drag
on till the first period it expired on
that day they sent to demand what was
due to them and the sultan returned the
following answer
you must choose either one of two things
either send our comrades back to us and
accept the installment due for this
period and we will give you hostages for
the performance of the conditions
imposed for the period still to come or
receive the installments we are sending
you today and send us hostages to be
retained until our comrades when now
your prisoners are returned to us
the envoys replied
we will do neither send us the
installment that is now due and accept
our solemn oath that your comrades shall
be sent back
the sultan rejected this proposal for he
knew that if he were to give them the
money the cross and the prisoners whilst
our men were still detained by the
franks there would be no guarantee
whatever against an act of treachery on
the part of the enemy which would strike
a great blow to islam
when the king of england saw that the
sultan was making some delay in the
fulfillment of the above-mentioned
conditions he acted treacherously with
regard to the muslim prisoners
he had promised to spare their lives if
they surrendered the city adding that if
the sultan sent him what had been agreed
upon he would give them their liberty
and so at about four o'clock in the
afternoon of tuesday the 27th he rode
out with the hold of the frank army and
advanced as far as the wells at the foot
of tel el ayadir as soon as the franks
reached the middle of the plane which
was occupied by the sultan's advance
guard they brought out the muslim
prisoners
whom god had preordained to martyrdom
that day
to the number of more than three
thousand
all tied together with ropes
the franks then rushed upon them all at
once and slaughtered them in cold blood
with sword and lance
the advanced guard had previously
informed the sultan that the enemy had
got to horse and he sent them some
reinforcements but they did not arrive
until the massacre had been accomplished
the following morning our people went
out to see what had happened and found
all the muslims who had been martyred
for their faith stretched on the ground
they were able to recognize some of them
this was a terrible grief to them
according to some the prisoners were
killed to avenge the deaths of those
slain previously by muslims others say
that the king of england having made up
his mind to try and take askalon did not
think it prudent to leave so many
prisoners behind in akka
god knows what his reason really was
the sultan thought it desirable to make
peace because his troops had suffered a
great deal and all their funds were
exhausted he knew also that they were
very anxious to return to their homes
and did not forget the unwillingness
that they had shown before jaffa when he
had ordered them to advance to the
attack and they had refused to move
reflecting therefore that if he came to
need them he might find they had gone
off he felt obliged to give them
sufficient time to rest
he was also anxious to set about the
reorganizing of the country and to
furnish the holy city with all the war
stones he could command
i was present at the council when it was
so decided
it was a day of rejoicing
it was known however that the sultan had
not made peace altogether of his own
free will
with regard to this he said to me in one
of our conversations i am afraid of
making peace and i do not know what may
happen to me the enemy will increase
their forces and then they will come out
of the lands we are leaving in their
possession and recapture those we have
taken from them you will see that each
one of them will make a fortress on some
hilltop
i cannot draw back
but the muslims will be destroyed by
this agreement
but god saw that peace must be for our
good because the sultan's death occurred
shortly after the ratification of the
treaty
had he died in the midst of the struggle
he had carried on
islam would be in the greatest danger
it was therefore by the special
providence of god that the sultan was
enabled to conclude the peace
himself
[Music]